[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about wet mo we've got and
today we have Stacey she is a you to bed
she has a very popular Instagram she has
her clothing brand called boom and which
she's wearing right now is really old
Wow she also holds an annual women
seminar that you and I went to this past
year and it was me the job feel sexy in
a power hell yeah yeah oh yeah you
should have seen tears were rolling yeah
I got cheese we run tears in dresses
that's what you should call the next one
that's sad okay nevermind I don't know
what was that I'm like okay okay okay
yeah so she's alright oh she's my both
of ours I guess her a Mexican connection
outside of this group that's dominant
added to my wrestling Mexican connection
connection if you need if you need that
Mexican connection hit me out following
yeah because every time with you yeah
that really comes out really you're more
proud of being Mexican when she's around
yeah I mean I'm always proud of being
Mexican but it may feel like more
comfortable move she has an outlet now
yeah cuz even with us like yeah we're
Mexican and we had to share that but we
don't fully like like dive into that
world like that part of us yeah
but then when you come you're like full
of it so I'm like yes blood turns to
Lucas bedroom I get interested she was
born in Mexico and then and that's what
we thought too about you you know but
she legit grew up in Mexico and I only
lived there for one year when I was 15 I
don't know where the idea came from and
if you look look me up on like famous
birthdays it says I was born in Mexico
born in San Francisco MIT not even close
so we're not more to Mexico
I was not born in Mexico so I hear I'm
mexican-american I have citizenship over
there but I just brought four there how
many years did you live out there for
from like almost 1:00 till 13 yeah you
really so did you learn English when you
came yeah I did it was really hard you
guys how my parents can make up their
mind where the walnut well it's about
making up their mind is about the
financial situation of the family
so when we were yeah you guys are corn
farmers no we were not so when we were
here I think you were tortilla makers
don't be racist no that's my Fiat but no
no it's all the work here I guess like
my grandpa told my dad like hey I need
you to take over this business so then
my dad took me and my mom back there and
she successfully took over that business
for years but then I feel like my mom
was like the backbone of the house the
one that was like come on you need to
work like you need to lazy ass stop
drinking tequila all day over there like
man a women couldn't be like the face of
the business so my mom was like come on
like you need to [ __ ] work you know
so my life story in a video when my dad
cheated on my mom and they separated and
my mom was like finding you want to be
out there then here you go like do
whatever you want and then my dad's like
mistress or whatever like she was like I
was only with you for money so now so
then that's literally when we were
really poor and my mom was like well I
have papers my kids have papers don't
cheat on your opportunity bleep that I
what kind of business was it my dad it
was a good drywall this is he was like a
contract oh yeah yeah gosh money but I
mean not anymore yeah yeah I dunno I
mean I didn't from 13 to like 23 you
know cuz it's rough yeah but now like I
guess as I got an older it's like I have
to open up like so when you were 13 you
came back to the states and then your
mom was like I could have an opportunity
here get like a stable job and all that
stuff and then you pretty much lived
here from that point on yeah I did so
she brought us with the idea literally
it was so crazy you guys she was like
we're gonna go to the US you guys are
gonna study English for a year that's
what she was like telling us you guys
are gonna study English for a year and
then we're gonna come back after a year
we literally left in the middle of the
night with Anna tell my dad so you ran
away literally we run away where did you
question it um we ran away cuz my dad
would have never let my mom take us you
know but he wasn't providing at the time
so she was literally like we're just
gonna go study for years so like if our
friends asked us or anything cuz she was
selling everything at the house you know
so when we got in the car in the middle
of the night like we're like all right
[ __ ] like I guess we're going over
there freeze off
all going from what yeah it's like a 20
at 16 hours but what like do stopping
your sleep somewhere yeah and I'm gonna
even that far down so now it's like
pretty close to like TJ and stuff like
you know but yeah it's crazy
yeah were you excited like we're gonna
go to America learn English I've already
been here before we would come like once
a year till I come shopping and stuff so
I was just more scared than anything cuz
it's like going to a new school but I
don't know what the [ __ ] anyone's saying
oh but I do know how to play volleyball
so that's how I like made friend that's
cool yeah let you learn already in
Mexico I played in 6th and 7th grade
over there and then I played in a 3 here
so like I didn't know in English but I
was like you know your dad you made
sleep you made friends like where's all
left ok was I he wasn't sleeping at the
same house that his mistress no she was
on his dad's house already so like they
had already separated uh yeah we were at
that main house so he didn't know that
you guys were selling um he'd knew but
my mom would be like I'm selling it cuz
you're not giving us money for food uh
she was like very sneaky about it her
family knew like my Diaz and stuff but
his family that I know and she actually
called us and like my mom was like don't
pick up the phone
I don't like it was really hard you know
like when you're in the middle of like
two parents that shit's whack as [ __ ]
like that's something I never want to do
put my kids in the middle of anything
you know but yeah my mom would be like
don't pick up the phone like don't tell
him where we are like especially because
he could have easily called like the
border and been like hey my wife is
taking my kids don't like them soon as
they see you then
they don't like to buy you know they
could have stopped her that yeah but
once we cross like the Mexican
authorities don't have any power over my
mom or us did you guys stop by a tacos
el gordo then what that wasn't beaming
Oh was it I don't think so I would have
stopped by I want to stop I'd be like oh
I think so in the priorities list like
cross safely
you know don't hit on my ex-husband
stuff that goes in you know our pastoral
with the final
I feel it I feel it what a great way to
enter the country right you eat that and
you're like I I'm ready to start a new
life
um we we drove all the way down one day
just to [ __ ] eat it really then drive
right back have you ever had the one in
Vegas yeah not the same really the food
was better yeah oh yeah yeah like it was
just that day cuz we went back and it
was good again I think this is a new
girl yeah nuclear man yeah it was brand
new
but now the girls seasoned mmm that's
pretty nuts I know you never know what
people have been through yeah it's crazy
out there was it hard coming to a school
year it was yeah because here like
people are super cholos and stuff and
like they wanted to fight me and I was
like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude what I
know like these twins their withdrawal
as girls yeah there was two twin girls
in eighth grade and like Here I am like
admit where I'm from like no one's told
or like that you know what I mean like
Here I am and like my I don't know like
regular ice tea sure like what the
cholera like I got UConn okay Riley yeah
that's like a thing here were you tall I
always been talking yeah yeah so like
these twins wanted to fight me and like
English I'm like [ __ ] first of all know
what the [ __ ] you're saying but
obviously I could tell something was
anywhere you a pickle we got to Pico and
I never left there didn't speak Spanish
not like bad I don't think I feel like a
lot of times like people speak like
Porto Spanish but like I spoke Spanish
period what's Bojo Spanish like when you
have a Michigan parents Spanglish yeah
like you know like they don't really
know like the right terminology yeah
you're what I speak you speak Pocho
Spanish no I feel like the fam this man
like you you still I could still you
could hold a conversational cape I never
minded that's not true everyone thought
you were local a woman went to Mexico in
Tulum they're like oh you talk like a
local I don't remember that memory yeah
cuz you were like really remember we
went to tell him I do remember that I
remember that remember we went that's
good
no but yeah every time I tried talking
to my family or even like how I'm saying
like you kind of bring it out of me like
I'm trying to like get it out I could
you get up in there yeah but it's like
it's kind of its lost in foggy and Mike
we need to watch more Spanish on TV or
like YouTube videos there's fellas who
were supposed to expand - that's true
oh yeah scratch your head more do you
watch Spanish YouTube yeah I do
I was yeah I want I should listen to a
lot of Spanish music that's literally
what I do
not a purpose this is what I like I do
like listening to a lot of Spanish music
in my my music there you go I feel like
you could practice it you guys gonna go
see that that man
dude that's a whole other life story in
itself
mine eyes like I feel like carries so
much like emotion for me like because
there's so many songs about art be tooth
grew up listening to and they're so
expensive to go watch oh I played them
for you the most famous Mexican band I
think I feel like you know yeah you know
I have like an insane connection to my
now because like my pajama cry was were
there I know girl just even thinking
about it because my dad was a huge
monofin and my night is from the same
sauna from inside both fun for where you
guys are dressed so for my were like the
city where my dad grew up is where they
would always go and play in the lobby
throw do like this one particular place
we would drink yeah so it was it's right
across from like there's a freeway and
my grandma lives here and then that
place is like right across this is deep
for both of y'all my it's not that deep
really yeah I just had really good
memories I was 15 and it was just like
the [ __ ] I had everywhere best time
in that like in high school it's deep
for me too because that when I was a kid
so my mom was poor so he still had this
is joke no it's real okay I never lose
my now I don't know if it's my now or
not but there's my mother were poor and
so after my parents got divorced she
would ran out the other three rooms and
one of the dudes was this Mexican dude
that used to ride a bike and worked at a
liquor store and he would always listen
to Spanish rock and he's taking a shower
it was my night and then he would bump
it and be [ __ ] loud out here I'm
seeing in the shower and I'm like oh
musics dope so I would stop like playing
in the backyard and just go in the
hallway of the house I could pretend
like I'm singing
know whatever cause if any introducing
me to Tiger's milk which is like this
little chocolate bar oh yeah I remember
the liquor store you would bring me back
is all Tigers nothing on thank you and
what they like the popular yeah the 80 I
think no I in like the 90s they
literally drop a single like every two
to three years some huggers book oh no
no no oh I was thinking about talking
Tigers no drop a new flavor yeah I was
like I haven't heard of it for years I'm
like if your parents like them I'm like
oh is that is it like their Rolling
Stone did start in the in the late
seventies it's when they formed and then
like in the 80s they like started
building attraction than 92 were like
baking hot but it's Spanish rock it's
not like traditional know but it's
Spanish rock but they do have like their
love songs that are more like just
acoustic guitar you know they'd be kind
of I feel like you're talking about no I
feel like in Mexico there's like not
such well there wasn't so many big
groups so that one group kind of does a
lot so I feel like they're like that
like they do a lot of different kind of
music they're Mexican my dad was oh
really yes so like I would when I was
little because he met them in the 90s
when they were gigantically huge and so
like when I was little my I was a chart
for my dad I would always hold onto
those photos and like I would listen to
this one CD Sueno kilos from 1997 that
entire and like I can [ __ ] sing like
my heart out so that entire album cuz
that session is what got me through my
parents really are they all like when
when bands get famous in Latin America
does it go all over cuz they the world
like within Latin America like so like
doo doo I don't know like people in
Spain or like
it's a Mexican ban but then like do they
go all over and vice versa yeah that's
cool that's really cool I mean I felt
like that's what we need I send me up I
was like ah for real like I felt so
happy and I was and I even told you I
was like wait how much is it cuz I
already know they're expensive already
looked into their tickets we had fuzz
Thanks yeah yeah and Bose was like
nothing worry I got it and I was like
like I don't know I just felt so I'm
grateful you know to me yeah me too I'm
excited I'm gonna wear makeup because
I'm gonna know cuz recently or not super
recent but Jess and I went to the cure
concert oh and then here was the other
band like the English band that my dad
and like I was insanely connected to
that Ben because of my dad so for me
it's my time to care and so when I went
to see the cure concert I was just like
well I should not have brought like put
makeup on Dan waterproof I know right
but like even filming things and then
when I got to see my dad after that
concert in Mexico and I was showing him
these videos I couldn't even get through
like telling him like how amazing it was
to see them live and like how I felt
connected to him and I was just like
bawling and then like Casey was all
vlogging I'm like how come you couldn't
get through telling him out there was um
because it's like this really deep
intense like emotional connection to the
music because like during that time that
they were that I was really connected to
it and listening to these album I was
going through like the worst time of my
life because it's it was my parents
divorce and then like and then my
stepdad coming into my life and like all
these things right so that's what got me
through it like it was literally like my
my like little like escape it make you
feel like you were back there again
at that time when you're listening to it
when I was in the concert yeah yeah yeah
it's tight
I think intense yeah yeah nothing like
booked my night I can't wear makeup no
no musics crazy how it could take you
back to like whatever PA whatever a song
you could be like in the grocery store
if you're a song you're like um
cry right now and then you say you
remember her had a song like that where
I want to cry right not know you
remember my sign reading I called on
that [ __ ] yeah and you don't like to be
vulnerable so a lot of the line songs
make me learn some Lion King oh yeah see
but that's they went beyond sir sang
that when Beyonce sang them were you
like I don't even watch the new ones I
don't want to ruin my childhood well you
better she's like I'm channeling you I'm
holding a bit music so strong man that's
how old Eminem CDs are for me
Eminem is that you're glad you cried
yeah yeah right my sister likes him a
lot too
mm-hmm we're like certain songs take you
back to a certain time in your life look
as he sings about such emotional stuff -
yeah because he will he was an addict I
think so he's like the vlogger of
rappers where I feel like I know his
life because he sings about his life and
he updates us like through his songs and
so like that was like a certain time in
his life that like it resonated with
stuff I have felt like I was going
through you know like an just certain
things hit and still to this day when he
comes out with new songs I'm like I can
relate to that
you know for me you have to meet him
dude you don't care I'm gonna lose all
my body fluids if I mean you told me one
time that just thinking that I shouldn't
piss all the same time throw up you're
not scared that if you meet him and he's
not everything you think you that's what
I'm scared of I get scared of that I'm
scared that like I just won't even know
how to form words dude house I think
about it and I start crying
anyone ever met you and they're like
that yeah but it yeah it's weird
and you're like no no like you're fine
like let me hug you you're fine I feel
like Eminem would feel like that about
you yeah he's also very private and he
gets like mass mobbed by fans like oh
yeah one person here and they're at like
a VidCon or whatever maybe we could
bring them on JK news and then we could
you can meet him on a plane one telling
you oh my god
would that be we bring him on and we
don't call me so funny she's getting you
bad hustle so hard I'm gonna meet him I
would take a picture of it can I just
kiss your cheek absent a send it to you
though ma
could do it on hey [ __ ] let's play with
that idea let's say he's he's sitting
here in a cry dude right when you walk
in the door like what would you do I
would [ __ ] myself right I see this is
the real one or like that's true cuz
like that could be I pull that on you
you almost did that one really yeah he
almost hired an Eminem impersonator
right now he might be too famous let's
wait like 12 years and then he could get
on the show yeah legendary saying he's
gonna stop making music but he keeps
making music okay he's relevant we just
released the album last year but I see
still a thriving us he was like in the
early 2000 oh he's not at his peak
anymore but he's still held a mega
famous
yeah that's what we do we gotta we gotta
wait till all these celebrities age like
wine and then they'll come to our child
or you can step it up and then good you
can use to the level yeah we've been
trying no it's too much of course I do
I'm that Aries what else oh my god where
is positive Y yeah Sagittario you guys
don't feel it oh yeah by the way we're
mentioning all these things it's because
on patreon we did a Nicki did an
astrological reading for every real
fight like it's a real fight so yeah can
she get me back right yes you gotta get
on patreon to see all that is everything
I say was it 100% real it's not like a
[ __ ] that's why she's attacking
every bad for you why sure why does she
want to get revenge on us yeah because
you're hurt her Oh cute I love your
that's hi I'm excited to go to a concert
yeah you get to join us yep you so you
are coming yeah
oh I thought you were gonna be in Hawaii
huh no oh I knew you ended up not
leaving during that time but I still
don't know how we'll be back before them
before that before it but that can you
record some songs cuz I wanna maybe that
my childhood two keys you just played a
mama sit in the hallway and I'm gonna
cry
it's just talk cause it reminds him of
mega me the Tiger's milk you were
dancing isn't it happy - oh you're happy
tears
yeah they were Park who started the
story with like when we were poor Oh
whose order some Tiger's milk off the
internet no can also realize we had a
weird childhood like he wasn't a
pedophile or anything but I think he
knew that I liked singing along with him
he used to take showers with the door
open so we can I can shout into the
bathroom while he's shouting back more
like singing you all the Spanish words
I'm making up my own [ __ ] you're so good
at imitating Spanish whirring yeah you
probably thought I was cute I'll just do
just a thought yeah sounds just like it
what did I just say taquitos yeah but
how old are you at that time gotta be
between like eight or nine another
really good memory that young I thought
you I pictured you're way cuter yeah
now as I get my present divorce not six
it has to be after six but I think eight
or nine ish
[Music]